here are the best drugstore products I
tested in 2022. let's start with face
products the elf power grip primer
creates a really nice tacky base for
foundation that's meant to make your
makeup last longer my Foundation Blended
out really nicely on top of this and I
do think my makeup lasted really well
even my blush which is literally always
the first thing to disappear on my face
the elf Halo glow liquid filter is a
great dupe for the Charlotte Tilbury
Flawless filter it gives you a really
glowy your skin but better base these
versed mood lighting luminizing glow
drops are a similar product they do give
a beautiful glow to the skin but they
don't really have any coverage they do
have a lot of great skincare ingredients
that made my skin feel really nice and
hydrated this elf luminous putty bronzer
goes from this putty formula to a powder
up close you can see a lot of Shimmer in
this but it doesn't look that way on the
skin this is one of the most blendable
bronzers I've ever tried and it brings a
really natural warmth to the skin
Milani's conceal and perfect contour and
high later are really good these kind of
feel like a drugstore version of the
Charlotte Tilbury wands the Contour
Blended out really beautifully and the
highlighter gave a pretty glow without
emphasizing my texture the elf Halo glow
Powder Puff has become a staple product
for me it does pick up a lot of products
but this sets makeup so beautifully and
it's such great quality like you
wouldn't think this is four dollars the
Jason Wu Beauty blush Trio is more on
the pricey side of the drugstore but I
think it's so worth it the blushes all
blend out so easily and look so smooth
on the skin the color payoff on these is
also great moving on to eye products
this Jason moo Beauty Flora four palette
was surprisingly pigmented and easy to
blend also this Jewel stick was
incredible look how much it brightened
up my inner Corners the elf lash and
roll mascara really coats every single
lash my lashes are so straight but this
gave them a nice curl I wish it
thickened my lashes more but for six
bucks this is a really good drugstore
mascara these NYX jumbo lash lashes are
so easy to apply and the band is really
comfortable I think these have totally
convinced me to wear lashes more often
the Nyx Thicket stick it brow gel is a
thickening brow mascara if you look
really close you can see those little
fibers that are supposed to make your
brows look fluffier I really like the
natural full brow effect you get with
this next let's talk about lip products
this is the Maybelline Super Stay vinyl
ink long wear no budge liquid lip color
this is a long wearing lipstick that's
meant to stay shiny you have to shake it
for five seconds then apply even though
I did get a little transfer and the
shine isn't long lasting the lipstick
itself stays super bright and doesn't
budge these are the L'Oreal coloration
tense volume matte lipsticks the color
payoff on these is so good and they
apply really smoothly this is one of the
most comfortable matte formulas I've
ever tried especially from the drugstore
the Jason Wu extra pout lip plumper is a
Holy Grail product for me even if you
don't care about the lip Plumping aspect
this is one of the best lip gloss
formulas I've ever tried it's so
cushiony and shiny and amazing and
everyone should get it this elf cookies
and dreams lip gloss in cookie dreams is
a black lip gloss with a bunch of pretty
blue and silver glitter throughout on
its own it gives a bluish black tint I
love it more over other lip products
it's really good for deepening colors in
the formula of the gloss itself is
actually really nice for the four dollar
price point I only tested one hair
product this year and that was the Eco
Styler unicorn glitter gel it's a
translucent pink color with blue
iridescent Sparkles running this through
my hair you don't really get the
glittery effect you can see the glitter
and color better when I apply it to
brushed back straight hair this is so
cute for a little glitter moment every
once in a while and it actually washed
out of my hair easily
[Music]